all right
more Doctor Who stuff to cover okay so I
talked about trailer now let's talk
about the stuff that got brought up at
the panel in Hall H at San Diego
comic-con where they had Jodie Whittaker
Chris Chibnall one of the executive
producers and two out of three of the
new companions I didn't memorize all
their names I apologize but we did learn
a little bit in terms of details about
what is coming in the new season and
most of what was said was stuff I wanted
to hear so some of the basically the
highlights because I did watch the
entire hour-long panel so so that you
don't have to hear the basic highlights
of specifics that were said you know
aside from just anecdotes shared you
know what's it like working on the blah
blah blah blah blah which is not
uninteresting but I kind of had to slog
through that stuff to get to the stuff I
actually was interested in hearing lots
of emphasis on new not just for the
doctor but for the adventures for the
things that that she is going to
encounter lots of emphases on how much
is new and that I am game for I like
Doctor Who's attachment to its history
as a show however it can at times become
overly massive Ettore especially I think
more than anything when it comes to most
of the series arcs and you know building
to a finale against a returned classic
series villain pretty much every time
series one the Dalek series two the
Cybermen and the Daleks series three the
master series for the Daleks and Davros
the specials the the master again plus
the Time Lords we got on things a little
bit different
series 5 but they basically just shoved
everybody into that series 6 okay
different finally that episode didn't
take the landing but like that's one of
the few exceptions series 7 what we had
the great intelligence again series 8
we had Cybermen and the master Missy by
this point series 9 we do well the Time
Lords Rassilon so kind of new kind of
old but it was also hell-bent and then
series 10 Cybermen and the master again
I mean we just keep cycling through
these same things over and over and over
again and as happy as I am to get them
back I want more new stuff I want more
freshness and I and that was one of the
things I was really hoping Chibnall was
planning to bring was just more stuff
for the show to play with in the future
cuz that's that's the problem with
becoming overly enamored with the stuff
you've already done is you start you
start recycling you're not building an
equal amount of new stuff to be able to
call back to and I I'm so that excites
me since I mentioned the series arcs
there was it was set a couple of times
actually by Chibnall that these are 10
standalone episodes that specific phrase
was used now does that mean definitively
that there's zero connective tissue
between adventures no it absolutely
doesn't but it does mean that we're not
dealing in two parters and it one would
assume that if there is an overarching
story you know in the nature of bad wolf
cracks and time silence will fall etc
etc the hybrid and so forth that it's
going to be something that it is not
central to the plot of most of these now
strictly speaking that is kind of how
they started doing series arcs that
harkens back to like series one two and
three where you got things like you just
keep hearing bad wolf over and over
again until you find out what that means
in the finale or you hear Torchwood
repeated several times until you find
out what that is in the finale or you
get a number of references to Harold
you find out who that is in the finale
so potentially they could still do that
I'm kind of hoping not I'm honestly kind
of hoping that there is no overarching
series arc for this for series 11 and
that's not me saying never do it again
and that's also not me saying that it
was never done well just saying can we
take a break from that speaking of
things were taking a break from it was
not said definitively it was not said
outright that the Daleks will not appear
in this series
it was pretty heavily implied though
what what Chris Chibnall said when asked
by the the woman who was hosting the
panel you know I think she asked
something to the effect of you know
what's it like to work you know with
dalla she was asking about you know
older monsters and what Chris Chibnall
said was well we've got two weeks left
to shoot and we haven't seen a Dalek yet
now does that definitively mean there
are no Daleks no there's two weeks left
to shoot but that would mean that if
Daleks do appear in this new series it's
going to be in a minor way either well
it's gonna be one of two things either
it's gonna be frankly a little bit like
they were in say series 10 where they're
basically a one-off scene you know just
a random thing for them to bump into and
move on from or on it's gonna be
something where they end up being behind
something and we end there kind of the
surprise reveal behind what else is
going on and that would require you know
only a couple of days of shooting with
the actual machines so saying that they
haven't seen a Dalek on set yet does not
mean they aren't there but it is also
distinctly possible that the reason he
put that emphasis on it you know not
wanting to say definitively because he
kind of didn't want to say anything
definitively which I don't blame him for
but he he was really heavily implying
this kind of don't hold your breath for
Daleks
kind of thing tone to his voice and if
the Daleks get a legitimate hiatus like
year off thank you like I've been
begging for that like not zero I think
we need a year of no dot not not even a
requisite cameo we need to need to not
see them for a series and I'm now kind
of hoping that's got to be the case I'm
not gonna like pitch a fit if we end up
do if we if if we end up do god oh it's
been a long weekend if we end up
actually seeing a Daleks you know I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna throw my hands
will go but I I would really like them
to not if it is an option for them to
not actually put them up on screen so
because that's something that's always
kind of you know you get varied stories
on that but I'm not gonna get into that
again so I like what I heard it in
addition to the trailer which I already
talked about I it gives me just a lot of
reason to be excited for this
I love the emphasis on new I like that
Chris Chibnall said it's being designed
as a jumping on point and that's part of
the reason why there's so much new stuff
and I think that's good because I don't
think we've had like a truly legitimate
jumping on point since series 5 because
you would think each new doctor is
potentially jumping on point but that
kind of hasn't been the case you know
series 1 obviously is designed does it
jumping on point series 2 when we got
Tennant I mean technically he started in
the Christmas special and that special
didn't really make a lot of sense unless
you had the context of what had come
before it when we got Matt Smith that
was very much a jumping off point that
was pretty much a clean slate in many
many ways
when Capaldi came in while deep breath
doesn't totally fail as a jumping on
point it wasn't really designed to be
there's too many callbacks to too much
stuff we've got a holdover companion
that first adventures with characters
who were introduced previously it's not
really a strong jumping on point so
designing this as a jumping on point I
think I think is also a wise idea
because I think there's gonna be a
decent number of people who maybe aren't
going to check out the show for if not
for the first time ever for the first
time in a while because of the new
doctor and I do
wonder cuz I I don't I never follow the
the viewing numbers the ratings I don't
care I just don't I care I care insofar
as is it getting canceled because the
numbers are so low if the answer is no
that I don't care what they are
so I never followed that but more than a
few people have said and I should have
looked this up I should have confirmed
that but I didn't know I was gonna talk
about this is the effect of me rambling
which is what I do but more than a few
people have cited how the numbers
weren't great throughout Capaldi's run
and I do have to wonder if part of that
is by the fact that his first episode
was not new viewer friendly to be frank
about it because one would think that a
new doctor should be a big draw for new
audiences but when that first new
episode it doesn't feel like it caters
to new audiences well you're not gonna
bring them in and then you know shows
tend to hemorrhage viewers over time
more often than not and it's just a
question of what your retention is but
when whenever they get a new doctor that
is a chance to bring a whole either a
whole new bunch of people in or to bring
back people who maybe decided you know
what capaldis era wasn't working for me
maybe Moffitt's entire room wasn't
working for me Oh new creative team new
doctor I'll check that out and so I
think it's it's wise to not have it
overly soaking in what had come in the
previous series previous seasons so that
everything that they said was stuff I
was happy to hear now that all lays out
the theories the principles the guiding
philosophies of how they're approaching
it does that mean they will actually
stick the landing and it'll be as good
as I want it to be no no because you can
have the best ideas of the world you
fail the execution it doesn't matter how
good it was on paper but if it is a good
idea or a Toledo to what I like of
Doctor Who for what I want from Doctor
Who this these are all things I wanted
to hear and it waylaid some fears
because I said after I finished
broadchurch that I was concerned that
because so much of the strength I saw in
ship nose riding him
I seem to be linked to serialize
storytelling I was really concerned that
he was gonna try and bring that to dr.
who he put in Phasis on these being
standalone so he's not doing that which
was a sigh of relief because that was a
concern for me so the more I find out
about this new series the more excited I
get it took me a little while to warm up
to the casting and get over the shock of
it but I'm excited for Jody the more I
see of her and seeing her on the panel
seeing her enthusiasm and I loved her
answer if you didn't see the panel
I loved her answer cuz they got asked
who would you cause play outs she was
the first one to answer she immediately
jumped up to the microphone she said
sloth from the Goonies that's a great
answer that was awesome
so I'm loving the enthusiasm I'm seeing
from this group you know Chibnall I I'm
not gonna say he's completely done away
with my concerns cuz I can still look at
his writing and go I there's reasons to
be worried here but the approach he's
taking is the approach I would like him
to take so it's just a question of
sticking the landing at this point
pretty much everything is lining up in a
way that I'm going yes that can work so
now it's gonna be down to execution and
we won't really know till the show start
airing oh well so I'm not quite done
talking about Doctor Who yet a little
bit later this week I am gonna talk
about the new sonic screwdriver we had a
couple days so until then the San Diego
comic-con
Doctor Who panel have you seen it did
you just read a write-up on it I what
was said whatever your thoughts are on
anything that was said or that I said or
whatever well just drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about
there's all this stuff to do such as
like and subscribe and you know I'm oh
god I almost started going through the
whole list and I'm trying to stop doing
that you know what the stuff is I have a
page around that's kind of a big one but
there's links for all this stuff down in
the description if you care and if you
don't don't worry about it and until
next time this councils adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]